[Musique]
j'aime danser
oui oui j'aime danser danser parce que
ça me rend heureux
ça me rend heureux j'aime danser parce
que parce que parce que parce que parce
que j'aime danser parce que ça me gêne
dans c'est parce que ça me rend au tapis
j'aime danser parce que ça prend j'aime
danser parce que j'aime danser parce que
j'aime ça malheureux j'aime danser parce
que ça me rend heureux
[Rires]
cette histoire se déroule au ghana et
nous présente des passionnés de danse
[Musique]
mal ms je m'appelle saké persie sur les
réseaux sociaux je suis connue sous le
nom de percy jackson
le professeur qui danse j'ai 25 ans je
vis a hobo quoi et je suis apprentis
professeurs
[Musique]
je m'appelle à jackson
je vais à l'école primaire a hobo
presbytes
[Musique]
je suis en première année classe je
m'appelle prince assante je suis en
première année j'ai quatre frères et
soeurs j'aime aller à l'école ma matière
préférée c'est les mathématiques
[Musique]
j'enseigne les arts créatifs les
technologies de l'information et les
maths
j'utilise la danse pour rendre
l'enseignement plus facile et pour
attirer les enfants à l'école pour qu'il
vienne au cours à l'heure et se plaisent
à l'école les études intéressantes quand
je serai grande je veux devenir avocat
plus tard je veux devenir policier
pendant mon temps libre j'aime beaucoup
danser et je m'entraîne beaucoup
[Musique]
percy jackson n'est pas tout puissant il
est fonctionnaire il enseigne dans une
école de village
une carrière qui l'a préféré à l'idée de
rejoindre l'armée persie est convaincu
que la danse renseignements plus riches
il vient de lancer sa propre fondation
il voudrait diffuser son message au delà
du ghana il veut introduire la danse
dans toutes les classes du monde
[Musique]
ça c'est ma soeur pire
selvi derrière chez moi et vent de l'eau
glacée à la cantine de l'école
là elle enlève quelque chose de blanc de
mes cheveux elle est vraiment très drôle
ce vendeur vient ici chaque matin pour
vendre du coco ce monsieur est fermée et
il se rend sa ferme
lui c'est au pin
il est en 6e année c'est un garçon très
bien et il est très sérieux en classe
[Musique]
tout cas ces deux là sont d'une autre
école je leur ai demandé un peu de pain
à l'aide parce que j'aime avoir une
interaction avec des enfants
on appelle ces gens et zinda la gare ils
nettoient la ville pour qu'elle soit
toujours propre voici mon école primaire
au bo presby voici mon école primaire
beaupré ici c'est mon école par école
les enfants courent souvent à ma
rencontre quand j'arrive à m'en mais bon
parfois je fais semblant de ne pas les
voir je les évite
voici ma classe la première
les enfants aiment suivre jusqu'à la
classe et quand je suis à l'école nice
ils veulent être autour de moi donc je
suis allé poser mon sac
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nicole classique c'est comme une école
militaire
asko de mon point de vue la danse
fonctionne mieux que les règles
classiques de l'école
[Musique]
bercy ne pense pas que les enseignants
devraient toujours exigé la discipline
de la part de leurs élèves
pourquoi alors interdire de faire du
bruit de s'agiter un bon enseignant doit
organiser la foule devenir son leader et
permettre aux élèves de canaliser leur
énergie de manière créative
[Musique]
après l'école bercy va aider son cousin
dans un village voisin
ils produisent de la papeterie et des
accessoires pédagogique pour l'école je
peins les porte crayons nous les
utilisons pour garder les crayons et les
stylos j'ai l'habitude de venir
travailler ici mais c'est aussi pour
donner des idées pour les matériaux
nécessaires
ces matériaux facilite l'apprentissage
et je comprends comment ça fonctionne
c'est pourquoi je viens ici tous ces
supports pédagogiques rendre
l'apprentissage plus facile je propose
aussi d'utiliser la danse plus on
pratique plus on retient facilement les
choses
donc pour ce qui est de la danse quand
on danse on réfléchit mieux et tout
vient plus facilement
[Musique]
je pense qu'il est sur une bonne voie
grâce à la danse il se rapproche de ses
élèves
ja comment expliquer la danse n'est pas
le principal
mais elle réduit la distance entre le
professeur et l'élève
[Musique]
on
il ya et déjà la cantine de l'école
oui c'est bien la cantine de l'école
persie se prépare pour son cours la
france reçoit son cahier d'exercices et
envoie l'un pour hadja kunz a comme les
classes sont surpeuplées trois étudiants
partagent un bureau les seuls supports
visuels disponibles dans cette école
sont les murs de la classe
merci on est persuadé si l'école ne peut
pas se permettre d'équiper ses classes
il peut au moins rendre les cours
divertissante où et quoi
excellent très bien
très bien c'est correct la méthode de
persil est simple si on peut danser au
lieu d'expliquer alors il faut danser
vous êtes prêts si vous êtes prêts oui
non dit oui monsieur vous êtes prêts oui
messieurs après on y va
[Musique]
le jeune homme aux tee shirt sur lequel
est inscrit le mot réalisateur est l'ami
des cols de persil ils l'aident à faire
ces vidéos sur instagram
ils discutent maintenant de la prochaine
publication de persil aujourd'hui il m'a
tagué dans une de ses publications sur
instagram instagram est une partie
importante de sa fondation
c'est par ce réseau social que le monde
fait connaissance avec la méthode de
persil
[Musique]
le multi
donc
quoi
[Musique]
alors si vous voulez danser dans la cour
mais la pluie l'a forcé à changer ses
projets
pour moi enfin mes chaussures et tout ce
que j'ai au pied d'un ça ne tient jamais
très longtemps parce que je danse
pendant des heures certains surtout
quand on tour d'une vidéo milieu
[Musique]
pour moi c'est un vrai problème
je voudrais que mes chaussures ne
servent plus longtemps coquet laffont
[Musique]
le compte instagram de persil commence
tout juste à devenir populaire
il a déjà 19 1000 followers
avec la popularité arrive aussi les
critiques
[Musique]
un défi pour savoir qui serait le
meilleur danseur a été lancée à percy
il a décidé de relever le défi bien sûr
qu'il y a des personnes qui me détestent
mais j'ai beaucoup de followers sur
instagram ou d'autres réseaux sociaux
et naturellement il y en aura toujours
qui ne t'aiment rompt pas et vous savez
plus on me déteste plus je suis motivé à
continuer ce que je fais
[Musique]
merci nous montre la maison où il a
grandi où réside toujours sa mère et ses
frères et soeurs je m'appelle confort
boateng est percé monfils calais voilà
mon frère belle quoi en tout c'est le
deuxième fils de la famille voici mon
oncle sam fort il est aussi enseignant
au lycée je pense que la danse donne aux
enfants une liberté ça les a beaucoup
aidés elle permet aux élèves d'être plus
proches de leurs professeurs comme s'ils
se disaient ce sont nos amis on n'a pas
à avoir peur d'eux les élèves n'ont plus
peur de leurs professeurs voici ma ferme
c'est une petite ferme vous savez juste
derrière ma maison et ça fait un moment
que je ne suis pas passée par là tout
n'est donc pas dans le meilleur état
possible mais j'ai planté des plantains
avant de partir et vous voyez ça pousse
petit à petit nom donc on mangera
bientôt des plantes intériste
oui si je danse c'est pour rendre grâce
au créateur le ton que sa mère prépare
le dîner persie nous montre sa chambre
[Musique]
voici ma chambre j'ai fait ça au centre
de production des supports pédagogiques
c'est une croix vous savez je suis
croyant je les mises sur la porte pour
qu'elle me protège de mauvaises ondes de
spirituel c'est mon système audio ah bon
je lui ai acheté il ya environ sept ans
il est je l'utilisent comme un studio je
n'aime pas enregistrer mes chansons en
studio mais j'aime jouer des instruments
et les accompagner en chantant parce que
je voudrais améliorer mes compétences
[Musique]
j'ai mes marie cardon
oh
[Musique]
ici
mais aller
[Musique]
pendant son enfance
mais si aimer la musique et les tambours
un jour nous sommes allés à l'église
il a trouvé des bâtons et s'est mis à
frapper sur les tables p our house j'ai
voulu le frapper moi même mais le prêtre
m'a dit confort ne fait pas ça allait se
jouer tu ne sais pas ce qu'il deviendra
[Musique]
l'après-midi persie enseigne aux enfants
à danser dans la cour de sa maison
[Musique]
percy et prince forme déjà un joli duo
ils font cette danse lors des festivals
locaux france est donc déjà un vrai
petit artiste
[Musique]
et après les cours de danse
ils jouent au football mais le football
est très important pour les gagner ou
que vous vous rendiez au ghana vous
verrez des enfants jouer au football et
même des adultes jouent au football
[Musique]
la danse et le football ont beaucoup en
commun
la danse tout comme le foot est une
forme d'exercice physique et sa forme
optimale et un site web donc oui on
faisait ça c'est comme faire du jogging
dès lors c'est une autre forme de danse
et parmi les élèves
il y en a qui ne savent pas danser mais
savent jouer au football
damned je suis là pour les réunir neuf
et nous travaillons ensemble
on apporte des corrections
le football est une profession et on
peut gagner beaucoup d'argent les gens
s'entraînent avec application pour s'en
aller loin là où ils croient qu'ils
seront bien payés
[Musique]
aujourd'hui a lieu une dernière
répétition à l'école la veille du
concours de danses folkloriques persie
est en charge de la répétition les
danses folkloriques existe toujours au
ghana elles font même partie du
programme scolaire
[Musique]
regardez cette danse est très inspirante
elle s'appelle ou sous des années elle
est normalement interpréter lorsque le
roi se repose
[Musique]
7dans cela s'appelle kitty
les zorra c'est l'une de nos danses
préférées
et celle là s'appelle à face à faux
c'est une danse royale interprété par
des clans cette danse est normalement
pratiqués
quand les gens se réunissent les habits
sont faits de matériaux rares comme le
kit ibis sa tasse de thé bis c'est une
danse très intéressante
tous les gestes tous ces signes
symbolisent des louanges
le drapeau est le symbole d'un clan
c'est un guerrier et il porte le drapeau
du clan cette danse est normalement
danser avant le début d'une guerre
7dans cela s'appelle bachchan c'est une
danse récréative qui réunit les hommes
et les femmes
elle est dense et dans l'est du ghana
par l'écho bout elle est accompagnée
d'une chanson du même nom
la danse a lieu après les rites de
purification
elle symbolise l'unité et l'amour entre
les gens
[Musique]
le drapeau symbolise aussi l'unité
génétique
une nouvelle journée d'école mais il
fait assez froid dehors
c'est pourquoi à jack hounsa prend son
petit déjeuner dans le couloir se
préparent aussi pour l'école sa mère
était occupée avec son petit frère
donc le petit déjeuner n'est pas encore
prêt il le mangera à l'école l'école vis
des bons élèves
le directeur laisse une bassine en
plastique dans la classe pour les pièces
les dons sont aussi accompagnées d'une
danse
[Musique]
dans cette partie du ghana le samedi est
la journée des morts c'est le jour où
les gens procède aux enterrements et
prix pour leurs morts lorsqu'un proche
meurt
ce n'est pas seulement une affaire de
famille mais un événement d'une grande
importance sociale par exemple les
funérailles ici ressemble plus à des
soirées mode toutes sortes de problèmes
importants sont résolus lors des
réunions comme celle ci aujourd'hui est
une journée particulière
nous pleurons les morts et nous avons
dans ce spécial pour nous la danse ont
généralement lors des funérailles
elle a en exprimant aussi notre
tristesse ainsi la tragédie de la mort
se transforme petit à petit en une
célébration de la vie
le chef
il est venu avec la reine sur le lieu
des funérailles pour commémorer leur
famille
femmes 1 l'homme avec le parapluie est
annonciateur celui qui porte le chapeau
est le roi et comme vous pouvez le voir
l'annonciateur fait des louanges au chef
au roi la danse du roi s'appelle à doha
doit aller normalement ce sont les akan
ce qui la danse
après le départ du roi et de son
entourage
la foule continue de danser
[Musique]
et le message de cette danse est simple
un être cher est passé dans un monde
meilleur et il faut se réjouir pour lui
[Musique]
samedi soir les danses funéraires sont
terminées et il est temps d'aller en
boîte de nuit
percy et ses amis ont décidé de se
détendre après leur semaine de travail
et bien sûr
tout le monde danse
[Musique]
quand nous allons à l'église nous
dansons quand nous allons aux
funérailles
nous dansons et même dans notre lit nous
dansons de quoi parce que ça fait partie
de nous so what s pourquoi s'en priver
pour éduquer les enfants à l'école
bonjour seigneur jésus bonjour je sais
que tu venu du ciel le son esprit est
assis sur le trône qui aiment notre
professeur qui aiment notre professeur
[Musique]